the smell of rubbish fills hillbrow it's
a poor neighborhood in Johannesburg many
people in Africa's wealthiest city don't
have electricity running water or
sanitation for tulani fetching water is
a daily task
living in a very terrible situation and
we are appealing whoever might help that
I need maybe toilets
obviously what is life yeah we need
water
lengthy electricity outages and no
running water have become more frequent
as power stations and water pipes
haven't been maintained
under South Africa's Constitution
everyone has the right to basic Services
Civil Society groups have taken the
municipality to court but with little
success
the city doesn't show any sympathy when
it comes to a poor person they make sure
that they treat you in a bad way that
will make you feel that you are not
welcome in this particular office
tolani's building isn't the only one
with problems the stench of sewage and
clogged toilets has made other buildings
unsafe for residents my country is
falling apart my city is falling apart
and I said I will not sit back and the
people of Johannesburg have voted for my
political party to come they've given us
a chance and I must prove myself to them
and my party must prove itself that
indeed we are about service and servant
leadership
playing with failed infrastructure for
years people here say they feel hopeless
but have nowhere else to go
and 29 years after they voted for a
democratic government they have yet to
enjoy the rights they were promised
Al Jazeera